come on hasn't everyone here dreamt of
flying so why haven't humans flown yeah
I've been obsessed with learning to fly
my whole life I grew up a feral adopted
child on the northern shore of Lake
Ontario following my trick layer
fishermen father around I was always
fascinated by things that moved catching
small animals holding them in my hands
feeling the magic of their movement
playing with fire thrilled and terrified
it it's unrelenting forests accidentally
burning my father's barn down just once
that was my first brush with real danger
the fire and my father when I was about
eight or nine years old I caught a fly
in a mason jar studying that fly I
thought wow it's changing directions in
midair with acute angles and it's going
so fast it's a blur why can't we do that
can we everywhere I looked there were
things moving and these things moved
with their very own causal rhythms their
very own mechanistic anatomies it was
clear to me and to Newton that things
move based on their component parts
worms squirm birds flu kangaroos hopped
and a human's first bout with flying was
falling accidentally tripping or
slipping on that fabled banana peel once
your ground is dragged out from under
you a world of wonder comes rushing in
I had found my territory I was seized
with a compulsion a primordial urge to
learn how to fly like a human for the
next ten years I did my experiments
alone on my own body I drove my Honda
350 across the United States in an Easy
Rider kind of way I got my degree in
modern dance I mimic that fly in the box
i do' horizonte threw glass on the
way I punched a hole in it I was trying
to figure out something about flight
when I was 27 years old I found myself
in a rat-infested New York City loft
getting ready to hurl myself off a
ladder I climb higher higher higher and
I jumped whammo
I landed that hurt and it occurred to me
that people didn't really enjoy getting
hurt and that may be the reason that we
weren't flying yet is that we were still
attached to that false idea that we
would fly the way birds do or
butterflies maybe we needed to
Assumption bus to ask a different kind
of question about duration for instance
humans in the air a few seconds birds
and butterflies minutes maybe hours and
what about fear I think fear is complex
and personal I really think it has to do
with curiosity and not taking yourself
so seriously we might need to get a
little hurt just not to hurt and pain
redefine it rather than pain say another
rather interesting foreign sensation
something like that I realized then that
to learn to fly we were gonna have to
learn to land my hero Evel Knievel one
of them said anyone can jump a
motorcycle the trouble begins when you
try to land it landing hurts
I was curious though I thought well why
don't we invent an impact technique why
don't we just expand our base of support
I had seen pieces of plywood fall and
they didn't flinch on the way down so I
made my body into a perfect line and
tilted back waft it was a totally
different sound than whammo and I rushed
down onto the streets of New York City
and went up to complete strangers and I
said well I thought I did a bad fall
today did you in 1985 we started to tour
all over the world
a little bit and I started my company
called Streb extreme action in 2003 we
were invited to go to Kittyhawk to
celebrate the 100th anniversary of
flight with the Wright brothers we had
gotten very good at landing now we
needed to get up into the air and like
them we wanted to stay there longer I
came across this quote by Wilbur if you
are looking for perfect safety you'll do
well to sit on a fence and watch the
birds but if you really wish to learn
you must mount a machine and become
acquainted with its tricks by actual
trial ah machines it incited the
hardware junkie inside of me and if we
did want to go or travel down habitual
places in space to that banana peel spot
that confuses us to that place outside
our vertical comfort zone where we
encounter unexpected turbulence and get
accelerated oddly where the ground
changes and moves out from under us like
the composer who's trying to hit a note
higher than the human voice can sing he
invents a piccolo or a flute
I've said about the invention of my
prototypic machines and if we wanted to
go higher faster sooner harder it was
necessary that we create our very own
spaceships and we did and we did travel
to unknown invisible dangerous
territories and it changed us if any of
you want to try this let me know in 2012
we brought all of our best machines to
London and put them in their most iconic
places we got on the London Eye and it
was 443 feet above the earth and as we
reach the zenith we unlocked our break
and found 200 feet on the radius on the
spoke that we were attached to we
reached as far up as heaven that day I'm
pretty sure of it and an eye and two of
my dancers walked down the outside of
London City Hall as I stood up there 300
feet above the ground and looked down I
saw 2,000 eyes
with me and they saw what they usually
do the sky a bird a plane and then us
you just a tiny speck up there and I
realized that action is for everybody
now we have a very own mason jar in
Williamsburg Brooklyn and it's called
slam Streb lab for action mechanics and
it was a former mustard seed Factory and
I designed it after the use of a petri
dish and in that petri dish I put kids
action Streb extreme action and circus
arts and we all learned to fly fall and
land and invent extreme action together
and you know what we found
in comes everyone every size shape age
capacity every nationality every race
every class all genders the timid in the
bowl the outcast in the cool the risk
avoiders and the risk obsessives and
these buildings exist all over the world
and they every one of them can be a
flying training center and you know as
it turns out people don't want to just
dream about flying nor do they want to
watch us fly they want to do it too and
they can and with a little training they
learn to relish the hit and the impact
and I guess even more getting up
afterwards I found that the effect of
flying causes smiles to get more common
self-esteem to blossom and people get
just a little bit braver and people do
learn to fly as only humans can so can
you come fly with us
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]